en el vídeo pasado olvidé mencionar que
como cualquiera de las dos opciones nos
da la respuesta entonces aquí tenemos
que responder de saleh pasemos ahora al
problema 16 el problema 16 lo que nos
pide es determinar si x es mayor que 1.8
que es algo muy sencillo ver si x es
mayor que 1.8 y tenemos como inciso 1 de
información que x es mayor que 1.7 x es
mayor que 1.7 que por supuesto no es
suficiente para responder si es mayor
que 1.8 porque x podría ser digamos 1.75
o bien x podría ser igual a 2 y aquí si
le gana pero aquí no vale entonces este
de aquí no es suficiente y como inciso 2
tenemos que x le gana a 1.9 y estoy aquí
si es suficiente si le gana a 1.9
entonces por supuesto que le gana a 1.8
y entonces con esto si podemos responder
esta pregunta vale esta pregunta y
entonces aquí la respuesta sería b
muy bien vamos ahora al problema número
17 en el problema número 17 nos piden
determinar si el entero n bueno tenemos
un entero n y nos piden determinar si n
1 es impar
un bar esto básicamente es lo mismo que
preguntarse si n es para verdad es par
porque si tenemos un número y el que le
sigue pues uno tiene una variedad y el
otro tiene la otra si n 1 es impar
entonces en sparc tiene más uno es para
entonces en es impar
no quiero complicar este problema mucho
porque es un problema muy sencillo vale
bueno entonces ésta de aquí es la
pregunta y los incisos que tenemos los
incisos de información son uno saber que
n 2 es un entero para n 2 es entero
y como inciso 2 tenemos que n 1 es
center o impar n 1 es entero impar impar
sale bueno vamos con el primero si
sabemos que n 2 es un entero par pues
por supuesto que n spark si si nos
movemos dos números o sea si de n vamos
a n 2 y empezamos con un par pues
volvemos a caer en un par por ejemplo de
4 a 6 empezamos en un par y llegamos a
un par de 3 empezamos en un impar y
llegamos a un impar vale otra vez no
quiero complicar mucho esto pero bueno
tiene más 2 es para entonces n tiene que
ser par entonces esta información de
aquí es suficiente para para responder
le voy a poner palomita y ahora vamos
con la segunda saber que n 1 es centauro
impar
bueno pues una vez más llegamos a esta
idea de que dos números consecutivos
tienen distinta paridad si n uno es un
entero impar entonces al sumarle uno o
sea al pasar a n lo convertimos en un
entero par y entonces en espa y por lo
tanto n más uno es impar otra vez es una
idea muy sencilla vale entonces esto de
aquí también es suficiente
para responder la pregunta y por lo
tanto aquí tendríamos que ponerle de
vale de vamos al problema 18 de problema
18 nos dicen nos piden determinar si uno
es menor que equis y es menor que dos o
sea si x está entre uno y dos pero no
puede ser uno y dos tiene que ser
distinto porque esto de aquí es
desigualdad estricta vale bueno en el
inciso 1 de información nos dicen que es
0 es menor que x estoy aquí pues claro
que no es suficiente verdad si sabemos
que x le gana a cero pues x podría ser
un medio no está en este rango o x
podría ser 1.5 y si está o x podría ser
algo muy grande como 10 millones y
entonces no está esta información de
aquí no es suficiente para determinar si
x está en este intervalo vamos a ver qué
sucede con la información del inciso 2
en el inciso 2 nos dicen que x es menor
que 3 y x es menor que 3 tampoco sirve
verdad o sea si x es menor que 3
entonces x podría ser 2.5 entonces no
está o sea x podría ser igual a 2
5 y entonces no está en este intervalo o
x podría ser igual a menos 7 verdad solo
sabemos que es menor que 3 entonces no
está bien x podría ser igual a 1.5 y
entonces si estar entonces esto no nos
da la información que necesitamos y qué
sucede si juntamos las dos si juntamos
las dos pues únicamente sabemos que es
cero que cero es menor que equis y es
menor que tres o sea que x está en el
intervalo de cero a tres sin incluir los
extremos pero eso tampoco nos dice gran
cosa verdad como el intervalo de 1 a 2
es un subconjunto del de 0 a 3 pues
saber que x vive aquí no no tiene por
qué decirnos o no nos dice si x vive si
x vive por acá una vez más algunos de
estos ejemplos nos muestran por ejemplo
este de acá estoy acá cumple ambas
condiciones pero queda fuera del
intervalo de acá del que está entre 1 y
2 y este pues cumple estas condiciones y
queda dentro de este intervalo entonces
ni siquiera juntando ambos pedazos de
información podemos determinar si x está
entre 1 y 2
y por lo tanto la respuesta aquí sería y
muy bien respuesta y vamos muy bien con
el tiempo llevamos como cinco minutos
quizás vamos demasiado rápido pero bueno
vamos a seguirle me parece que estoy
diciendo las ideas claramente sí sí de
repente me acelero demasiado sería bueno
que que me lo comentará pues ahí en
youtube vale bueno vamos al problema
número 19 en el problema número 19 nos
dicen más cosas es un problema escrito
un poco largo dice está entrando agua a
un tanque a un cierto ritmo constante
por una tubería al mismo tiempo está
saliendo agua por otra tubería a un
ritmo constante ok entonces déjame
pintar el tanque por ahí está el tanque
y está entrando agua digamos a la razón
x y está saliendo agua a ritmo constante
digamos a razón que lo voy a poner y lo
que nos piden determinar es en qué razón
en galones por minuto déjame ponerlo
aquí galones por
aquí también galones por minuto entonces
nos están pidiendo en qué razón o en qué
proporción en galones por minuto está
aumentando el agua en el tanque ok
entonces entonces vamos a ver está
entrando a equis galones por minuto y
está saliendo a llega lunes por minuto
entonces el flujo de agua es x-men x-men
de galones por minuto
sale cada minuto entran x galones y
salen y va entonces pues si queremos
saber en cuánto está aumentando pues más
o menos nos están diciendo que x menos y
es positivo para que esto sea de veras
aumente y lo que queremos es determinar
exactamente cuánto es este ritmo de acá
o sea cuánto es x menos y necesitaríamos
tener xy pero vamos a ver qué opciones
nos dan vale va entonces las opciones de
información son 1 opción 1 de
información de saber que la cantidad
inicial de agua en el tanque la cantidad
inicial de agua es 200 galones 200
galones le voy a poner aquí 200 galones
eso por si mismo suena medio inútil no
por qué
si sabemos que empieza con 200 galones
no sabemos nada del flujo a lo mejor en
el inciso 2 nos den pues la situación
del agua en otro tiempo o algo así vamos
a ver qué dice feliz y so2 dice que el
agua entra al tanque a razón de 10
galones por minuto entonces eso ya es el
valor de x verdad entonces nos dicen que
x es igual a 10 galones por minuto y
también en ese mismo inciso nos dicen
que sale que sale del tanque a razón de
10 galones cada dos minutos y medio 10
galones cada 2.5 minutos y eso cuando
existe entre 2.54 entonces esto es 4
galones por minuto y eso es justo lo que
necesitamos para encontrar x - de verdad
no tendríamos que hacerlo basta decir
que con encontrar bueno con saber la
información de 12 es suficiente
vimos que esta no pero con saber 2 es
suficiente pero vamos a hacerlo si así
quisiéramos hacerlo tenemos que restar x
osea x menos 10 menos 4
la razón a la cual está aumentando el
agua es 66 galones por minuto
vale entonces la opción 2 de información
fue suficiente para responder el
problema y entonces la respuesta es ve
ve muy bien y finalmente déjame hacer el
problema 20 el problema 20 lo voy a
poner por acá en color rojo y el
problema 20 dice lo siguiente nos
pregunta si x es un número negativo ok
x es menor que cero y de opciones nos
dicen 11 que 9 x le gana a 10 x vamos a
pensar tantito en este si 9 x le gana 10
x entonces podemos restar 10 x de ambos
lados y nos quedan 9 x menos 10 x le
gana a 10 x 10 x es decir menos x le
gana cero y aquí multiplicando por menos
uno de ambos lados cambia el signo nos
queda que x es menor que cero creo que
se podía hacer más rápido desde acá
verdad restando 9 x de ambos lados
tenemos que x
pero a bueno de cualquier forma este
inciso si sirvió para para resolver si x
era menor que cero no y el inciso 2 el
inciso 2 nos dice que x + 3 es positivo
x 3 es positivo positivo y esto no
parece ser suficiente información verdad
si x 3 es positivo x podría ser menos 2
por ejemplo x podría ser 20 y bueno ahí
tenemos un valor positivo y uno negativo
que cumplen entonces ésta por sí misma
no nos permite resolver el problema y
por lo tanto la respuesta sería a voy a
hacer uno más porque se ve se ve que
está cortito entonces me voy a poner por
acá que es el 21 y en el 21 nos piden
nos piden decidir si 12 m2 m 13m es
igual a 0
pues esto de acá es exactamente lo mismo
que preguntarse si 12 m es igual a 13 n
si es simplemente una manipulación
algebraica en la opción 1 nos dicen que
m es distinto de 0 pero esto no nos dice
gran cosa verdad que me es distinto de 0
puede ser 20.000 y de ahí podemos
determinar n bueno vaya no nos dice nada
acerca de esta igualdad
entonces esto de aquí no es suficiente a
lo mejor juntando lo con el inciso 2 sea
de ayuda el inciso 2 nos dice que 6 m 6
m es igual a 9 n y estoy aquí si se ve
más interesante
ambos son múltiplos de 3 vamos a dividir
entre 3 a ver qué pasa
dividiendo entre 3 nos queda que 12 m es
igual a 3 cn y eso es justo esta
pregunta de acá verdad o sea ahora
restando 3 n nos queda que 12 m menos 3
n es igual a cero y eso nos permite
responder esta pregunta entonces aquí
este es suficiente y por lo tanto la
respuesta es b nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo para hacer más de estos problemas